le dernier Super Bowl a été joué ici
Jason me dit que c'était un classique classique a donné
80 000 personnes sur leur haine secondes restantes
sur l'horloge ici B lance un Je vous salue Marie
[Musique]
166 de retour en ligne il y a soixante ans res a été
attaqué nous avons gagné la guerre mais ils ont
détruit  la moitié de la planète tout le monde a
été évacué il ne reste rien d'humain
ouais on est là pour réparer un drone avec une équipe de
ratissage
c'est Jack Harper
je suis prêt à partir encore deux semaines jack et
on peut enfin partir et rejoindre les autres
ne prends pas  toutes les chances
[Musique]
Je t'ai regardé jack tu es
curieux de savoir ce que tu cherches dans
ces livres est-ce qu'ils rappellent de vieux
souvenirs que nous n'avons pas encore identifiés
ne t'ont pas posé trop de questions
ils sont humains est  heure ultra habituelle pour
dire à Chuck comment tu connais mon nom
ils virent des survivants
ils arrêteront d'enquêter pour trouver ce que
tu cherches la vérité
c'est là que tu as été viré
tu n'as pas besoin d'avoir
ce que tu ne me dis pas qui sont  vous
- manquez de vous ordonner de vous retirer  n Je
ne vais pas faire
ça c'est la seule façon pour
toi
[Musique]